have a very burning question that's been
asked okay one second sneak out sneako
has to go so um thank you yeah thanks
for coming I wanted to sneaker to answer
this question real quick real quick okay
I have a very abundant question that's
been answered a million times but I
really need to like
um I still don't understand why do men
cheat like what are the top five reasons
it's just now it's just on our DNA it's
never gonna stop I don't even think it's
worth asking that question just accept
it if you want that level of guy you
gotta accept it so there's no reason
there's just a natural thing that they
just cheat it's natural for us to do
that yeah could you expand on that
well the first thing I would say is that
a man will you call it cheating I think
a real man is going to tell you how he's
going to be from the jump there's
honesty it's the deceit that's the
problem every woman knows that if a man
could he would you know so I think the
deceit and not only deceit is that a lot
of times what happened is you the man
himself is not even showing up how he's
supposed to he's supposed to make this
commitment to provide and protect and
make your life this wonderful place and
he doesn't and on top of that he's a
liar and he's a coward because he was
scared of you to tell you you understand
what I'm saying like that is the most
deceitful thing on the planet because a
lot of times when the man is [__] the
woman expects sexual exclusivity but
they don't really expect it from like we
talked about yesterday they're not
really expecting from Drake now are they
you know what I'm saying so it's when a
guy doesn't show up he lies and he's a
coward where a woman's like okay I'm
leaving for sure leaving but if a man
were to sit down tell the truth be bold
and and a woman is based enough to say
you know what any man on the planet if
he could be rich powerful
handsome whatever it is
he would absolutely have all the women
that he wanted I think the thing that
women
mistake when it comes to the subject of
infidelity or sleeping with women is
that they feel like he must love her or
that they're on the same level as the
other woman because a lot of times a
woman is less attractive that's not true
it's just it's just different and and
men and women women often tend to have
sex when they have true feelings for a
man men are just not that way
you know so it's it's the difference
between the Sexes but I think what's I
think women already know that it's the
deceit and the cowardness and the lack
of performance from the man that makes a
woman leave for that because if you got
a real good man that's a real good
father a real good husband a real
provider a real partner a real Rider
like somebody that'll sit down with you
when you're crying about it and like
really be there for you and hold and not
cry with you because we ain't crying
around here but but be there for you
truly and you know that they got you in
every way and you trust them and look up
to them and they're building you and
making you better dude you're not
leaving that guy no way
even if it hurts it even if you're gonna
say no right now
I've experienced it enough to know that
I'm right do high value men cheat
everyone
no that's not true that's actually not
true 99
thank you for giving that one percent I
appreciate it I don't want a cat but I
think 99 though yeah oh wait can we get
95 plus Pearl's Dad thank you
trigger you a year ago right when we'd
have this conversation we've done whole
shows about this yeah and now it doesn't
and I think that you see it through a
whole nother lens the whole show last
night was about it in the beginning of
the show the girls were pissed by the
end they were like I'd stay
you know and and it's it's just this
ugly truth about the word I don't like
it I said I told every girl last night I
would pay a million dollars to cut that
feeling off it is in us I saw something
a podcast the other day where a man said
if a man cheats women shouldn't take it
personal or should they should just suck
it up do you agree because I don't think
well so I don't like that idea of just
sucking it up if you if you if she's
like truly truly hurt by it I think you
need to sit in it with her and be there
for her like I look a real man can slit
a throat and hold a baby in the same day
that's my definition of a man so you
have to be able to do both you know you
need to be hard hard and loving and
there's no problem being vulnerable with
a woman or like hey being there for her
there's no problem at all because if
you're really strong if anybody takes
event tries to take advantage of your
vulnerability you [__] crush them so
you don't there's not one woman on this
Earth not one woman fully commit to
no no no no no no no yes there are there
are women that I can fully commit to as
in you sexually no there's no no and
there's no man that would want to if you
lined up every man on the planet and you
said Hey listen I got this red button
I've said this on podcast before
nobody's looking nobody's gonna judge
you truly nobody's here every man in the
world they said you can be a great
husband a wonderful father you can go
home tuck your kids at night possibly
sleep with other women and then go home
and hold your wife and tuck in your
babies and provide and be a good husband
and father every man on the planet would
look left they'd look right and they'd
hit that button do you think cheating is
a good thing
no but it is just naturally part of the
male psyche it's it's what I think the
point the point is it's it's it's he can
absolutely love the woman you know she
can be his absolute Queen she is like
the the top
um but he's always gonna have that that
propensity to what variety that's what
it comes down to and like Justin said
the other the other woman doesn't even
need to be that good she doesn't even
need to be as attractive she could be
ugly yeah I think these girls really
miss that and that whole time
the one he actually loves has the
ability probably to break his heart yeah
and and girls often ask well what's the
difference because I always thought that
if a man cheats he truly doesn't love
her oh no that's not true at all that's
not true at all that's not true at all
you know look I'm gonna tell you right
now honey hungry and horny to a man is
the same thing you have filet mignon at
home but sometimes you just eat a corn
dog because it's different so would you
say a hole is a hole
do you if it's female like well I got
certain standards right so you know no a
hole is not a hole but at the same time
you would be surprised at how far down
the totem pole a man would go for
variety and they don't love what they
don't love these women they don't even
want them in their bed what if a dude
got another girl pregnant do you think
that the girl should leave no no because
because it's really about him showing up
the way he's supposed to show up women
know men are this way all women in their
gut truly know men are this way and a
lot of times it's acceptable man there's
so many rap songs out there talking
about infidelity and [__] hoes and
[__] and the girls are in the club
just dancing what do you what do you
think are valid reasons for women-ending
relationships a man not holding the
correct frame not being the man of the
house being weak being in a position
where he's not being the leader not
taking responsibility not stepping up
not being a specific like example
um just like in a day-to-day
relationship of how that would play a
day-to-day relationship
I'll give you a great example men get
married every weekend in America they
stand in front of the church God and
both families and commit to the woman
they tell her they're gonna basically
saying they're gonna give her the best
life they've made an agreement for that
man to work his ass off he comes home
he's complaining about his job but
instead of getting out there and
hustling and creating a better life for
them and to be a better father and a
better husband he pops open a beer
smokes a j and turns on the Xbox
and he's just
emotionally vomited all over his wife
which puts her in a position of feeling
fearful like this guy he's coming home
complaining about his job not doing a
[__] thing about it and then dumping
it on me now I have to work so we can
make the mortgage now our kids not might
have to go to a lesser School than they
would have our whole situation is [__]
because this guy didn't make a
commitment and he's fine with that
because he's going to trade off sex
right but here's a news flash his ass
will cheat on you too and when you find
out you're gonna leave him but the guy
that's taking care of business every way
making you feel safe giving you a life
that you'd have never had otherwise is
committed to you and your happiness and
even is there when you're emotionally
upset or feeling pain that's the kind of
man you want
a man again my definition is a man is
somebody that can slit a throat and hold
a baby in the same day and that really
sums it up because he's got to be hard
he's got to be strong but he can still
be delicate if it needs to be because
he's so strong that he knows that he can
snap out of that really really fast
and that's it I still think cheating is
disgusting of course agreed if a woman
cheated on you would you stay [__] no no
it's a complete double standard it's not
fair at all I agree it's a complete
double standard it's not fair at all but
you know what I know well if a woman
truly loves a man she doesn't see other
men and then she can't even see him
I agree with that because there's been
times when I really like someone and it
doesn't matter how attractive another
person is see straight through him that
just I'm not interested yeah but a man
that creates an atmosphere of of being a
real man creates real genuine desire and
it takes genuine desire to make other
men invisible when other men are
invisible that's when you're doing it
right
when I have a Facebook account full of
wives sliding in my DMs I know all those
dudes aren't doing it right
yeah Facebook's the worst
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible